well my friends you did something quite
notable over the last 72 hours remember
that on Monday I came to you with almost
tears in my eyes and I told you about a
disaster facing many creators Like Me on
YouTube and I asked you take some simple
steps simple actions and many of you did
and the results are stunning and they
have turned up quite a bit of
interesting information now before I get
the results I'll quickly remind you what
went down on January 9th mysteriously
there was a six hour period during which
our live analytics on YouTube showed
that we were getting almost no views not
like 10 less than we normally get but
almost zero some hours we got 1900 views
when we would normally get 100
000 views this impacted our Channel it
impacted other people in and out of
left-wing Politics on YouTube YouTube
told us your views are fine it's merely
a reporting list which we're gonna fix
the glitch but views are completely fine
the next day things were supposedly
fixed and after three to four days some
slightly higher numbers were
retroactively updated in our analytics
for that weird six hour period on
January 9th but views were dead the
channel was dead subscribers were flat
one day we even lost subscribers after
gaining subscribers basically every day
for years and years we actually ended
the day with fewer subscribers than we
started
since January 9th the Channel's been
anemic videos that after 90 minutes
after two hours have two thousand or
fewer views again something that hasn't
happened for years do the math you know
this is just a mathematical reality we
come to to learn these things from doing
this for so long with 1.6 million
subscribers the mathematical possibility
of ending up with 2 000 views on a video
it doesn't pass the sniff test views
down 60 70 percent Revenue down 60 70
percent subscribers at a crawl happening
not just to our Channel but to the
channels of others you know as well so I
asked you to do something really simple
first search YouTube for David Pacman
click on one of our videos in the
results do it a second time do it a
third time the key is search for me and
then click on my videos we are training
the YouTube algorithm when you click on
my videos make sure you are subscribed
many people watch the clips but don't
subscribe that's bad for us in the
algorithm and make sure after
subscribing you click the bell and
select that you want to be notified
please like the video I said and if you
can please leave a comment the idea was
if YouTube shows you my videos in the
recommended videos you click on another
you comment you like you keep a string
going
this if nothing would show that if there
was nothing nefarious that took place
maybe we fell out of the algorithm
because of that glitch on January 9th so
maybe we can fix it so here's what went
down as soon as that video went live on
Monday at 4 pm Eastern explaining what
was going on we started promoting the
hell out of this video we dumped every
resource we had massive dumps to
artificially Drive traffic to the video
as much as we could the video picked up
over 450 000 views as of yesterday and
even more now
and something incredible happened that
video generated more than 13
000 new YouTube subscribers but did it
fix the algorithm is the next question
well
yes and no
the next video we published meaning
Monday at 5 30 Eastern was a video about
Donald Trump's absurd eulogy of diamond
from diamond and silk and that video did
okay it got about 200 000 views still
really good so it seemed as though the
activity from the 4 pm video did help us
in the algorithm when the next video
went live but after that things sort of
went to crap again but there are some
really important takeaways here it seems
and again we are working with zero
transparency so we're just kind of
feeling around in the dark it seems that
we can force our content back into the
recommendation engine it seems that the
dumping everything we had into that four
o'clock video did lead to more
recommendations for the 5 30 video but
then things trailed off things aren't
sustaining themselves the way they used
to so for now the good news is if we
keep at it if we keep trying to retrain
the algorithm in this way as I'm talking
about it might pay dividends it also
might not okay so please keep it up keep
up the like comment subscribe stuff now
I I also want to mention because people
have emailed me and said David you sound
extraordinarily naive I am not so naive
that I believe we can fix this ourselves
alone
and reporters have reached out to me
since this video went out they're
talking to me and other YouTubers about
what's going on I'm hopeful that an
article or more than an article will be
written about what's going on and
published soon to maybe shine more of a
spotlight on this in the meantime please
keep doing these things they are simple
and they are free and if you can afford
it get a membership at joinpakman.com we
are down in Revenue dramatically we were
counting on the YouTube Revenue to
launch the Spanish language YouTube
channel which is scheduled to launch
soon so if in addition to those free
things you can get a membership for a
couple bucks a month you can do that at
joinpakman.com of course you get the
bonus show why not oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
as bad you get the whole thing and you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now to
get yourself a discount but thank you I
mean just incredible what folks have
been able to do